In the last few videos, we
wrote a nice little program here
that asks the user for
some type of an input,
and then computes the
factorial of that number,
and then prints it out.
And that's nice.
But you could
imagine a world where
you would want to calculate
the factorial multiple places,
or in multiple
different programs,
or in the same program,
you want to calculate
the factorial multiple times.
And you don't want to have
to write this code over
and over again every time you
want to calculate a factorial.
So what I'm going
to do in this video
is define a function that
calculates the factorial.
And then we can use
that function every time
we want to calculate
that factorial.
So essentially, what that
function is going to do
is going to put all of this
code right here in one place.
And then any other
program that I
want to calculate the factorial,
I can just recall that code.
I don't have to rewrite it.
So let me just show you
what I'm talking about.
So I'm going to
define a function.
And the key word in Python--
so it's a special word that
tells the interpreter
that something special is
about to happen-- the
key word in Python
for defining a
function is d-e-f.
So I'm going to
define a function.
I'm going to call it
the factorial function.
And it tends to be a
good idea to name things
indicative of what
they actually do.
Sometimes beginning
programmers have
a habit of naming
things like x425.
And someone who
comes in later will
have no clue of what that
variable or that function
is all about.
So you definitely want
to somehow name it
so it gives an idea of
what it's supposed to do.
My function's called factorial.
And the user, when
they call factorial,
they need to tell
factorial what number
am I going to take
the factorial of.
So they're going to pass it
an argument called number.
And if these words look
a little confusing,
I'll explain them in
detail in a second.
But you can just-- hopefully
the more you see this,
the more familiar you'll
get with these ideas.
And so they're going
to pass its number.
And I'm just going to
have to return back
to the calling program.
And I actually
shouldn't even say
the user's going
to pass a number.
The calling program is
going to pass a number.
And I need to return back
the factorial of that number
to the calling program.
So let me write this down
as a comment, actually.
So returns the factorial
of the argument
of the argument number.
And sometimes you'll
hear the word parameter.
Sometimes you'll hear
the word argument.
When you're making a
definition of a function,
this is more formally
called a parameter.
Number is one of the parameters
to the factorial function.
The actual number that
someone else passes to it--
so let's say someone
calls factorial with a 3
here-- then more formally,
that 3 would be the argument.
So it returns the factorial
of the argument number.
And this is the argument
number right over here.
So I literally
mean-- I don't mean
this is just arbitrarily
the word number.
I'm literally talking about
this number right over here.
Maybe I'll say the
argument number.
Maybe I'll put it in
quotes to make it clear
that this is the argument.
I'm not talking about
any general number.
And let's define it.
So we're going to use the
same code essentially.
Actually, let me
just copy and paste
a lot of what I took over here.
So I'm going to cut that out.
And I'm going to
repaste it over here.
But I have to be careful
about my indentations,
because indentations
are how Python
knows what's part of what.
It knows how to
interpret things.
So everything that's part
of this function definition
has to be indented.
And we do it by four spaces--
one, two, three, four.
And this is another
four, two, three, four.
And then this is part of the
for loop, one, two, three, four.
And let's think about
what we have so far.
So it's going to be
passed some number.
We define this variable
product equals 1.
And we'll talk more about
scoping of variables.
But this variable is
only going to be usable
within this
factorial definition,
because the first time I
defined it right here is inside
of this right here.
So we'll go more into scoping
of variables in the future.
And then the same logic
we did before, for i
in range of number-- now
we're not getting number
using the input function.
It's being passed
to the function.
Then product is equal to product
times i plus 1, same logic
as we had before.
So after you go
through this for loop--
after you go through
it-- you're essentially
going to go through
number times,
product will have in it
the factorial of number.
Instead of outputting it
directly, what we want to do
is return.
We're going to return it
to the calling program.
And in the next video,
I'm going to diagram this
out a little bit
cleaner if this seems
a little bit confusing to you.
I'm going to return product.
So it's essentially the exact
same code as we had before.
But we've packaged it
inside of a function.
We've defined a
function, takes it,
it has a parameter
called a number.
If you pass factorial-- if
you want a factorial of 3,
you'd write factorial of 3.
And 3 would be the
argument, the thing that's
being put in the place
of the variable number,
or the thing that
number is referring to.
You define product
is equal to 1.
And then, you go number times.
So for i in range of
number-- and we've
explained the logic of that in
the previous video-- every time
you start with 1.
And then you do 1 times
1 is going to be 1.
And then product's
going to be 1.
But then i's going to be 1.
i starts off at 0.
So it's going to be 1
times 0 plus 1 gives you 1.
Then i is 1.
And so it's going to be 1 times
1 plus 1, which is 1 times 2.
And so it's going to be 2, then.
And it'll keep
incrementing that way.
And we explain that in
detail in the last video.
And then finally, it's going
to return that product.
So if we want to have
the same exact behavior
as before, but now we're using
this function, what we could do
is-- we could say, we'll
still have the input.
So this is our
function definition.
But then, along
our main program,
we've defined our function.
And now, we can just
say, look, from the user,
get a non-negative integer
to take the factorial of.
And let's put that
into-- let's call
that a variable
called user input.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to define another variable
called factorial of user input.
And now, this is going
to be interesting.
I'm going to call
this function up here.
So this is going to
be equal to factorial
of whatever the user had input,
so the factorial of user input,
the factorial of this
variable right over here,
the factorial of user input.
So now, factorial of user
input will be storing--
or I guess we
should say, it will
be pointing to
the actual answer.
And now, we just
have to print it out.
So now we can print.
And now we can print
factorial of user input.
So they look like sentences.
But these are just
variable names.
And I'm naming this
way so you really
know what's inside
of those variables,
or what those variables
are really pointing to.
So factorial of user input.
Now the moment of truth is
always saving the program
and actually trying to run it.
So let's try to run it right
now and see what happens.
Let's see what happens here.
So at least nothing
broke so far.
So once again, so
I want to be clear.
The program started here.
But up here, all we
did is define this.
So it's not actually
telling-- it's not
creating any interaction
with the user.
It's actually not processing
anything just yet.
So it just defines
this function.
Then it goes down
to here and it says,
OK, look, get some
input from the user.
And that's what we're
doing right here.
And after we input
some number here,
then it's going to go--
it's going to actually call
this function with that
number that we put.
The number that we put's going
to go put in the user input.
And then it's going to call
factorial with user input
as an argument.
So let's try it
with the number 3.
And it did not work.
Oh, and I see why
it did not work,
because I had this left over
from the previous program,
which actually
makes no sense now.
So let me get rid of that.
It's a good lesson that
seldom on the first try
does something work perfectly.
Let me try again.
That was just nonsense
that I didn't even
realize was down there.
So let me try it again.
So let me try.
So a 3 again.
And it gave me a good answer.
It gave me the factorial of 3.
And what's cool now is because
now my Python interpreter is
assuming that this
definition has been made,
I can now call the factorial
straight from the interpreter.
If I had another program, I
could call it in multiple ways.
And now, you should
hopefully appreciate
why it's cool that
we made this function
definition, because
now we can calculate,
because I've defined
this function factorial,
I can calculate
the factorial of 4.
It's 24.
I could say the factorial of 5
minus the factorial of 3, 114.
I can take the factorial of 12.
And you can tell the computer,
even though this is just
interpreting all of this--
we'll talk more about
interpreted versus compiled
code-- it's incredibly fast,
faster than we can
really even fathom.
So this is a real
power of a function
is that I don't have to rewrite
the code every time now.
I can just call it with
different arguments.
So factorial of 2.
I can do it every time.
I don't have to
rerun the program.
And if I write other
programs that use factorial,
maybe I do some
things in [INAUDIBLE],
I can just use
this as a function.
In fact, I don't
even have to know
what's going on
inside the function.
And one of the other
powerful aspects of functions
is that-- let's say I write
a bunch of programs that
call-- so I have this
program right here that
calls factorial.
But let's say that you
come up with a better
way of writing this
right over here.
As long as your program,
that does the same thing
with different guts, the
end user won't notice.
So maybe you write a faster
way, or a simpler way,
of doing this, a way that uses
less memory or less CPU power,
then you could just
replace this later on.
And then the
[INAUDIBLE] program that
calls it, as long
as it still works,
it'll work for that program.
And it'll just work
that much better.